WHEN I RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN
2024, WE WOULD'VE CREATED SO
MANY JOBS.
IN FACT, I'M GOING TO RUN, I'M
GOING TO WALK.
>> ALSO SAYING HE CHANGE HIS
NAME TO CHRISTIAN GENIUS
BILLIONAIRE.
>> Juan: WAIT A MINUTE,
CHRISTIAN GENIUS THAT HE CAN'T
MIMIC TRUMP.
THAT'S NOT ALLOWED.
HE'S NOT GOING TO RUN.
I DON'T THINK SO.
THE MOMENT YOU DECLARE, HALF THE
COUNTRY DOESN'T LIKE IT.
THAT'S WHAT OPRAH AND
CELEBRITIES DON'T RUN FOR THE
SECOND POINT TO BE MADE, WHEN
YOU RUN YOU HAVE TO HAVE A FIRE
IN YOUR BELLY.
YOU HAVE TO WANT IT.
YOU CAN'T GET OUT THERE AND HOW
HE GAVE THAT STAIR TO THE
AUDIENCE, YOU GOT TO LOVE --
YOU'VE GOT TO ENGAGE THE
AUDIENCE.
RONALD REAGAN -- WHEN
RONALD REAGAN RAN, IT WASN'T
LIKE HE WAS A CELEBRITY WHO JUST
RAN.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENED?
RONALD REAGAN WAS GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA, HAD RUN FOR
PRESIDENT TWICE BEFORE.
YOU'VE GOT TO PUT UP WITH ALL
THAT.
>> Greg: AND THIS IS THE SAME
ARGUMENT WE DID AGAINST TRUMP
AND I'M ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
MADE THAT ARGUMENT.
REAGAN WAS AN ACTOR, TRUE, AND I
HONESTLY DON'T THINK TRUMP
THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO WIN WHEN
HE WAS GOING TO WIN THAT I
BELIEVE TRUMP HAS OPENED THE
DOOR FOR KANYE.
PERSUASION IS MORE IMPORTANT IN
POLITICS.
I SEE THIS WHEREVER I GO.
I LOOK AT PEOPLE IN DIFFERENT
WAYS FOR THAT PERSON COULD DO
IT, THAT PERSON CAN'T.
>> Juan: DO YOU THINK YOU
COULD DO IT?
>> Greg: HE'S A MASTER
PERSUADER.
THE ART OF BEING MEMORABLE --
I'LL PUT IT THIS WAY.
WHEN TRUMP GOT ON STAGE,
EVERYBODY KIND OF FADED.
>> Dana: I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
KANYE VERSUS BERNIE IN 2024 WILL
BE SO GOOD.
THE OTHER THING IS I ADMIRE HIM
FOR DECLARING HIMSELF A
CHRISTIAN, ENTIRE ALBUM ABOUT
IT, HE'S LIVING HIS FAITH, IT'S
NOT EASY TO TALK ABOUT YOUR
FAITH BECAUSE YOU START GETTING
ATTACKED FROM OTHER PEOPLE.
THE OTHER THING I LOVE ABOUT IT
IS HE SAID THE NEW YEEZY SNEAKER
WILL BE MADE IN CODY WYOMING AND
WILL MOVE THE HEADQUARTERS TO
CODY WYOMING.
AND THEY'LL MAKE GOOD SHOES
THERE.
>> Jesse: THE SECRET WEAPON IS
KIM KARDASHIAN.
KRIS JENNER IS PULLING THE
PUBLIC STRINGS HERE.
>> Emily: HE'S A PHENOM AND IF
HE DECLARES ABSENTLY HE WILL
WIN.
HERE IS WIPER HE HAS PART OF A
PLATFORM ALREADY BEEN TALKED
ABOUT AN ECO-CONSCIOUS FASHION
LINE THAT'LL BRING ALL OF HIS
JOBS TO NORTH AMERICA TO
SOUTH AMERICA.
HIS WIFE THROUGH CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM, MESSAGING FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR THAT BASICALLY
SAY, YOU ARE NOT A VOTING BLOC,
YOU ARE UNIQUE TO THE AMOUNT OF
CAPITAL THEY HAVE BETWEEN THE
TWO OF THEM ON THE TABLE ALONE,
$610 MILLION.
AND ANYTHING THEY PUT THEIR MIND
ON, THEY CAN DO.
NEXT TOPIC, IF YOU'RE IN THE
TOPIC FOR A NEW MATE, YOU MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER A CONSERVATIVE
BECAUSE A NEW STUDY FINDS WHO
LEAN RIGHT ARE BETTER DATERS BUT
THEY ARE MORE UPFRONT WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR AND VALUE
FAMILY AND FRIENDSHIPS MORE.
I'M GOING TO GO TO YOU ALSO, ONE